Steve how're you feeling today pretty
good if the Giants call and ask you to
play wide receiver what would you say is
funny so people said I probably should
consider it since my broadcasting career
has it taken off our response to him was
it hasn't taken off because that g5 is
already in the air ho-oh so you're not
interested in playing if the Giants call
no I'm not interested in playing I've
kind of did my schpeel
you know in the league 16 years 38 years
old for me it's a great opportunity I'm
you know I'm at home I started to create
a routine that I'm really enjoying my 12
year old son who's waited four years to
play football tackle football because I
was in Baltimore and I just wasn't um I
just
it really wasn't gonna sit well with me
if like my brother or some buddies of
mine would take my son to practice and
to games every day mm-hm just being at
just being a dad that just was not
something that I could be okay with and
so now that I'm done
I've enjoyed taking them to every
practice going to games you know a
couple of weeks ago I cut up some
oranges for halftime you know the little
things I have not gotten the opportunity
to experience because of my job let me
ask you about a couple things yesterday
what do you make a Ben Roethlisberger's
post game comments how many it's a guy
who's you know just being transparent
I'm a guy whose question itself I think
when we get older older players start to
we can start to analyze the numbers we
start to be able to allow ourselves to
do the percentage of success versus
failure and sometimes as older players
we overthink because these younger
players you just roll out of bed and go
you know you don't have to stretch
you'll need tape you just go so I think
you
a guy who was frustrated disappointed
and also take accountability which I
thought was very uh was very good
wouldn't you take away from the Cowboys
loss the one biggest thing I took away
is I I do think that Prescott is a good
quarterback and I have to say good
because he's only in the second year you
can't call somebody great after two
years that means all other people that
are in there ten plus years that are
actually really really good or great you
discredit those guys so I would say dak
Prescott is a it's a really good
quarterback he's not a game manager he's
a quarterback that kid gnome that the
offense can go through him and he
doesn't have to quote unquote
you know take the check down which
you've seen other guys do great example
as a you looking at the Kansas City
Chiefs for years
how long have people said that Alex
Smith is a game manager so that that's
why I use that and that that comparison
game manager versus a real quarterback
would you rather play with Rogers or
Brady if I gave you the choice I really
only care either one is I take either
one if I had to pick well if I say Tom I
had the opportunity that to travel there
but I signed with the Ravens so people
would say that um you know but Tom they
their office is so unique would you have
won a Super Bowl if you went to the
Patriots um when I became a free agent
on a 1 that year so good yeah yeah I
think so I'll say anything as a football
analyst football fan growing up loving
this game just to be a fan right now I
would love to play with Aaron because
you get to play in Lambeau you know the
atmosphere the you know the cheesehead
I like that atmosphere it always looks
fun on television so I don't say an
Rogers because of all the
circumstances with that with the history
with the Green Bay Packers
he says Steve Smith the NFL Network and
former NFL star no interest in coming
out of retirement to help the New York
Giants Cam Newton's he played well
yesterday I mean he he makes degree of
difficulty he raises it though with what
he said earlier in the week I can't get
a handle on his personality
you played with Tim do you understand
who he is I mean I could probably say
yes right now I but I have to say no
because I played wonderful minutes first
three years and whether good or bad and
different he's in is what seventh year
now people people grow people go through
transformations and over the last four
years I haven't been there I haven't
been with him the day to day to sit here
and say that I know him to a tee so I'm
very far removed from that just like we
haven't interacted and you know for
years so as far as on a day-to-day basis
to the magnitude we were his first three
years so I would say we both don't know
each other because we both have grown
did you not I mean did you when you left
that was it was was it awkward with your
relationship with him what do you mean
awkward I mean you said you haven't
spoken in four years we we've talked but
not the way we're every day I went to
work I saw him he saw me and we interact
you know what I mean
do you get what I'm saying like I went
to work I worked with him every day in
the last four years I have not worked
with him like today the only person that
I've really worked with today would be
my three kids so okay so there's no
personal relationship I guess we all
have our lives going on he has two kids
I have life going on - so what do you
expect out of Mitchell true Biscay
tonight
that's what you need question because my
Glennon I mean they ran the ball was a
hundred and 150 percent of the time
every time he lined up he was handing
the ball off you know and so I'm
interested to see are they gonna keep
the same clay called with mr. Biscay as
they did with my Glenna I don't think so
and is that to say that you don't
believe in my Glenn is passing ability
or that you were setting them up for
failure because I wouldn't say all the
passes that he threw was all his fault
when you're six foot seven and your and
you and you already have a slow delivery
and you're getting hit halfway through
you're delivering the ball goes up I
guess that's a quarterbacks fault not
the old lounge fault huh well snarky
there Steve oh just you knows just why I
watch them I've been watching a lot of
games and sitting there analyzing and
seeing why things are good and why
things are bad and sometimes people just
want to assume this guy isn't good
enough sometimes he has a lack of his
old line isn't stout he has a lack of a
pass game no playmakers and all they do
is run the ball I don't really see what
mitch is gonna do I don't see those
receivers you know blowing the top off
the coverage like they haven't done it
thus far in what four and a half weeks
yeah yeah well they do have a running
game it's just question of do they have
enough receivers to make plays as he
faces the Vikings coming up tonight
Seahawks in the Rams yesterday did
Seattle just plays these kind of games I
don't know how good Seattle is and it
always feels like that offense is just
struggling to get field goal why is that
I'm not sure I mean there was a lot of
hype a lot of things saying how go
Russell Wilson his band was interested
in as you go down that you have to look
on their roster to even know Jimmy
Graham's on their team you know they
gave him this big contract they traded
for him and now he's just kind of
rotting and you know I think that's a
shame because he's
talented titania he's Steve Smith future
hall-of-famer
aim for the NFL Network you can see him
every Sunday morning and I fell game day
morning starting at 7:00 a.m. Eastern
also the NFL Network has Eagles Panthers
coming up Thursday night Steve great to
touch base with you thanks for joining
us appreciate that son Steve Smith the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience